if you haven't finished watching
stranger things to turn back now
you can definitely expect spoilers ahead
the second season of stranger things
wrapped about as neatly as you could
hope for
Hawkins Indiana is once again safe from
the threat of the upside down under Mike
and 11 finally got bad dance yeah we're
still hurting inside for Bob and splash
the rest of the cast made it through the
season with nothing worse than a broken
nose and a few bruised egos but those
last few episodes came and went like a
lightning strike so let's take a moment
to slow it down and to look at some of
the finer points of what happens at the
end of stranger things to looming shadow
let's start by talking about the
interdimensional elephant in the room
the shadow monster the final frames of
the last episode essentially act as a
promise for season 3 reminding us that
even though the immediate threat from
the shadow monster has been stopped he's
still out there in the upside down
looming over Hawkins it wasn't quite the
cliffhanger we got in the first season
with a freshly rescued we'll still
tormented by visions and coughing slugs
into the sink but it proves that the
mind flayer isn't quite finished with
the residence of Hawkins as showrunner
roster 4 explained it they've shut the
door on the mind flayer but not only is
it still there in the upside down it's
very much aware of the kids and
particularly 11 it had not encountered
her and her powers until that final
episode now it knows that she's out
there so that strange thing is contained
but it's far from defeated and if he
found a way into our world once chances
are he'll be able to do it again gates
or no gates as we saw several times in
season 1 such as when the demagogue and
it broke through the wall of the school
the membrane between the worlds isn't
particularly strong where these things
are concerned closing the gates
thanks to 11 the gate between Hawkins on
the upside down is definitively closed
with the gate closed all that the shadow
monsters influence over our world is
apparently cut off as well we see the
demo dogs go limp and drop down the
tunnel and the vines in the tunnel
shrivel up that doesn't necessarily mean
the shadow monster can't find the way
back in but it's a good start power
surge over the course of two seasons
we've seen Elevens power grow steadily
and it's also apparent that she's much
more comfortable of the humdrum everyday
of telekinesis she doesn't get a
nosebleed anymore with every little door
she slams shut for example but closing
the gate clearly pushed 11 to a limits
and revealed some of the true power of
her abilities like the whole floating
thing what's unclear is whether 11 is
channeling her rage or exercising it in
that moment we know that she's focused
on some of the darkest moments from her
past and earlier in the season
Callie tried to get her to build her
anger as a source of her power when did
you find something something that
English
[Music]
now channel 8 is that what she's doing
when she fights back the shadow monster
or is she releasing all that rage once
and for all
broken hive mind whatever the shadow
monster is it controls everything around
it through a hive mind from the demo
dogs to the vine spreading out beneath
Hawkins it's a pretty scary setup as we
see a near the end of the season at a
moment's notice the shadow monster can
send an army of killer demo dogs
anywhere in Hawkins but were also led to
believe that it doesn't have perfect
control over its minions either when
Dustin runs into his pet demo dog dart
and the tunnels tartlets the kids pass
showing that it can break the shadow
monsters control over it if it wants to
that's an important detail that may very
well come into play in the third season
hopefully the kids will have plenty of
candy bars Haeundae cooking the virus
while hop around 11 head to the
Hawking's lab to shut the gate joist
Jonathan and Nancy go to hoppers cabin
with a comatose well and turn up the
heat on the thing living inside him
literally by using all those heaters joy
Jonathan and Nancy are trying to sweat
the virus out of well like a fever more
or less burned out of him it gets pretty
brutal but they're also saving wills
life if that thing was still inside will
win 11 shut the gate there's a good
chance we'll would have died along with
the rest of the shadow monsters hive
mind sure hopper was waiting for
Jonathan's signal to prevent exactly
that but would he have waited forever
Tunnel distraction of course the rest of
the kids aren't idle during the climax
instead of waiting at the buyers house
as ordered they head out to the pumpkin
patch to distract the shadow monster
while 11 and hopper worked their way
toward the gate in Hawkins lab their
plan just saw a bunch of stuff on fire
and hoped the shadow monster sends all
the demo dogs their way yeah not exactly
the best plan in the world but it works
maybe even better than they expected the
timing could have been a total
coincidence will grant moths but the
moment they set the tunnels on fire just
happens to be the same moment the shadow
monster finally leaves well the truth is
out sort of
during the epilogue one month after the
events of the climax we see a string of
government trucks leaving a now locked
Hawkins lab while a news anchor
voice-over explains that the government
admitted to killing Barbara from season
one so Jonathan and Nancy's plan worked
they got the truth about Hawkins LaBelle
to the public and also like they planned
it wasn't the whole truth not by a
longshot
instead of announcing that Barbara was
killed by a monster that came through an
interdimensional rift at the lab the
news claims that she was accidentally
poisoned by an experimental chemical
asphyxiant because as crazy conspiracy
man Marie Borman explained in Chapter
five sometimes you have to water down
the truth to make people believe it just
like this drink here we make it more
tolerable the upshot is the same however
by all appearances or kins lab is closed
for good
finally the citizens of Hawkins get to
go about their lives without the
government spying on everything they do
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your loved team
[Music]